hey everybody I'm Jillian I'm Dave
welcome to the show today we're going to
be watching for stories about people who
were destined to perform they take to
the stage whether that be dancing
singing ripping on a guitar we're going
to go hang out with them and check it
out so for our first story we're going
to go to the islands of Hawaii at a hula
dancing school and you might feel like
hula is something that you see women
doing but there's men who will advance
as well and they are shirtless for the
clip check it out even well I think a
lot of people look at hula as just women
dancing but um we love it man hula is a
story
to tell the story the way the ancient
hawaiians did you really need to put
yourself in that dance you need to live
like them you need to chant like them
you need to train like them basically
you need to become them
Jamuna even a new hobby allows the hula
school we perform all over the world but
in ancient times
warriors are actually recruited from the
hollow the chief would come to look from
the ranks of the advanced male dancers
Warriors were selected by the philosophy
of our Hollow is to kind of replicate
that hola el culo we're basically
telling warrior stories and to dance
like a warrior
you need a train like a warrior we train
in a private piece of land on the west
side of wall using only what ancient
hawaiians head whether it's rocks the
sand the ocean when we come to practice
we expect to die
which strenuous on the legs but it's
also to train your mind I tell myself
and the rest of the boys if I fall it's
because my body just gave up
[Music]
one of the hardest workouts we do would
be climbing the coconut tree sometimes
you reach the top and your legs are
shaking because you know you're holding
your weight and to look down knowing
that nothing is holding you you got to
kind of have this warrior mindset as
like you know that this is what I want
you know I'm going to get this you know
when the gentlemen come to hula they're
like a ball of clay that's cool more I
look at it as my responsibility to shape
them into better individuals better
fathers that are sons that are brothers
our goal is that when these men are done
dancing that they leave here better
people
[Music]
what hula does for me culturally it
still takes me back to Tahoe I used to
be
people sometimes are losing that a lot
for each other that love for each other
and hula just gives you that reality
checks man I'm dancing until my kneecaps
fall off and even after that I'm going
to do whatever I can for the hollow you
know we have this Brotherhood where we
take care of each other we help push
each other it's my passion and I look
forward to seeing where hula takes me in
life for our next story we're going to
be moving from Hawaii to southern India
and we're gonna meet Nina she's 74 and
she's also doing an ancient practice
it's pretty amazing
let's watch the story that they will
remember today but we're never as a
model and I don't want Liliana no more
even now or even 90 other wonders candle
[Music]
in the middle Nina doesn't and I have my
stomach I did one of it before y0t
Valentina
[Music]
Nina is the oldest known woman
practicing kalaripayattu an ancient
South Indian martial art the art of
glory expected to leave the Foursquare
hand six and heavy swords and shields
the only on the granilith Liz Lange and
mother Illuminati bottom of it
I'm mama Monica yes I'm method acting
like a mother is preferable to I happen
if I do I cut my da nakka nakka Burnett
from the pier on the now mama mama Adam
okay Kylie own another condo already but
it does it is very catty Romano riding
with someone freedom I'm sorry Jeremiah
okay I can well Morales ID but cannot
about the model every one dollar and now
Lincoln everybody cut Castaneda cards
are holding available Georgia Robo
download URL rotator on the pyramid
[Music]
alive or South America remember Kayla
would be under I think a number we get
it over water under possible under
saying what I embrace every piece right
now during a marginal working inverting
water would be over at around 1800 when
you can all Indonesia up next we're also
going to meet a woman in her 70s I
cannot wait for you guys send me her her
name is Beverly and she is amazing
she's been playing a sick blues guitar
in Atlanta for I think six decades and
she's played with legends like Ray
Charles and James Brown second out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
blings is our feeling and it is in
experience blues is about something that
happens in my life my name is Beverly
walked in I was born here in Atlanta
Georgia in 1939 Beverly Watkins was a
pioneer for women in blues when I was
playing back in the sixties that was
with no female guitar players not in
Georgia
[Music]
this is a place like a man but they're
using the wrong terminology the main
thing is because I play so good after
high school
Beverly began touring with the band
piano red and the meter toads shortly
thereafter she was opening for some of
the biggest acts in music we opened up
for James Brown DB Chien oldest resin I
played over two or three thousand shows
back in those days the auditors took
time and hope each other
her hard classic blues style has evolved
over the last 60 years touring with
different bands and eventually going
solo
I never stopped when they said I should
I didn't pay him no mind I kept going
yes this has gotten hard out there you
know if I clean houses I worked at car
washes I clean offices but I never
stopped playing my music
[Applause]
and she has no plans on stopping anytime
soon
well into her seventies she still puts
on a show for the crowd
it was keeping me living he can be gone
I'm gonna look good and have a good time
and get up there and do my thing for our
next story we're going to meet a guy
named Ryan Lowry who is another musician
and he was born and raised in Compton
but plays traditional like suicide
let's watch the story
[Music]
since our faces that don't let me
perform simply because I'm black that
doesn't really get to me because I'm
trying to show the world that you know
music is universal we can unite us all
my name is Ryan Lowry and I'm also known
as SM scenario and compañero simply
means the black friend
I see original musica mexicana panda CR
n yo norteño mariachis yo soy americano
yeah mexicanos yo got a little I've been
around Hispanic so I mean it actually
comes naturally it flows out I grew up
in the streets of Compton I live in a
neighborhood that was predominately
black and Mexican it's a wonderful thing
to say you know I came from Compton
because they say a lot of people don't
make it out I've traveled to a lot of
places and I'm all over TV and I can say
hey I'm from comfort I like people tell
me like hey you're supposed to be
Mexican God just let you know in too
long I know for a fact I am
african-american but yeah I do still
like I live that life I have lived the
Ranchero life I've had horses I've had
research goats hey everything I know how
to saddle up a horse your honor making
dance and everything a lot of people
misunderstand and say hey it's going to
be Mexican too much I'm like Walt there
are American Cowboys there are people
who use Boop and just that's what I was
taught what I've been around but yes
like I said in my
but like I said in my song I have the
heart the soul of a Mexican and that I
think that pretty much will count
[Music]
thank you so much for watching these
four great big stories click on the
horse to subscribe and let us know what
you think in the comments below thanks
for watching and we will see you next
time